hey guys I'm going to show you two
different ways to get the zoom feature
in Windows Vista the first way is with
your mouse so what you're gonna do is
click on your Start menu and I'm going
to use eater now to show you what I'm
typing click on the Start menu and type
in search mouse and hit enter Microsoft
Mouse will come up and it will show you
your mouse properties what each button
on my mouse does now this is my actual
mouse it's a five button Mouse and you
can watch my review on it earlier in my
video subscribe for more and if you're
watching this in HD you can see what
each one of these is here we go left
click button right click button the
wheel button in the middle the rear
thumb button which is the back and the
front thumb button I've set to magnify
so what this does is every time I press
it the screen does this little flap
thing I'll do it again looking white
thing and then it doesn't magnify it
it's a really sweet magnifying box but
it's kind of annoying for it to do that
all that flashing every time and when I
puts it again BAM it's gone so that is
how that is how mm-hmm
that is how I use the Microsoft Mouse
software to zoom in and out and on
textile I pick up doing if I want to
show you something
or show you what I'm looking on so
that's how I use that part the second
way to get the magnifying feature is to
go into to go into your Start menu again
and type in magnifier and hit enter
because the first one will be a program
called magnifier those know how to fly
yes it does slashing but at the top of
the screen it'll show me where my mouse
is on what I'm clicking so if I go to
the bottom the screen come up here
notice at the top it'll show me an
in-law enlarged version of what I'm
clicking and it's pretty cool it's built
into Windows this day so you don't have
to download any and stuff you can see
the name of it is you know you can see
all the things that I'm active clicking
on so you don't have to you don't even
have to watch it in HD to see what IMAX
we seen but it is always nice to watch
in HD whenever you want to close it go
down right click it and hit close and
magnifier will close so I hope you
enjoyed that really it's a very simple
way no software needed to do the second
way which is built into Windows Vista
and the first way all you have to do a 5
button Mouse and install all the drivers
and make sure you set one of those
buttons on the mount to be a magnified
button you just hit the drop down menu
and go hit and magnify for one of those
hit ok and apply and then whenever
people after a little bit of annoying
flashing will be able to see exactly I'm
clicking on at all times and that's how
you get it so I hope you liked this
tutorial subscribe for more I'm doing
tons of videos now guys so yes alright
peace out